all right franchise tag deadline today
at 4 pm eastern unless they move it
there was talk yesterday of the nfl and
the nfl pa moving it because the salary
cap isn't set yet
and it's hard to know for the base
franchise tags what
the value will be without knowing the
salary cap actually it's impossible to
know because it's driven by a percentage
of the cap
two tags reportedly applied justin
simmons
bronco's safety and no brainer guard
bread and sure
both of those you don't need you don't
need to know the tag the cap
because it's 20 bump over last year
because they both got tagged
last year jets safety marcus may
reportedly will be tagged
he will have the base level once we know
the cap that's when you do the
calculation taylor moton the right
tackle
of the panthers same deal there yeah i i
expected there to be fewer this year now
dak getting a deal done is one fewer
on top of that but uh look this is a
year
that's it's strange it's screwy and the
salary cap is going to affect everything
and
that franchise tag amount typically is a
large number we're still keeping an eye
on allen robinson of the bears
dollar day of the lions those are the
guys who could be tagged shaq barrett
could be tagged again in tampa
yeah if they can't work out a long-term
deal so look it's a deadline driven
thing i still don't understand chris why
they do two weeks
all that matters is one day the last day
when the window closes
yeah no you're right that's all that
does matter like i mean kenny gallaudet
i
i can't imagine them letting hit you
know hit the free agent market
there's no way i don't think shaq
barrett will hit it either i'd be
surprised if they don't get franchised
here at some point soon
i mean the other ones that you showed on
that list there i mean brandon sherf
even with the 20 bump it's still like
he's not being paid like the highest
guard in football it's a no-brainer he's
one of the best guards in the game
washington's got a lot of money i would
think they get that done justin simmons
you know you've heard me say over the
last few weeks he's definitely one of
the three or four best safeties in
football and for the vic fangio scheme
is very important what that position he
plays there like there's no way they're
going to let him hit free agency
i would expect they get a long-term deal
done there taylor moton
or moton right the right tackle for the
carolina panthers
he's a road grader he's the best old
lineman they got on their team
they got o-line issues and you know
they're trying to build something and
bring in
maybe a desean watson or draft a
quarterback or do with that i can't
imagine them letting him out of town and
as you're seeing that i mean there's
reported he's going to be franchised the
one i do find interesting is marcus may
of the jets you know because his career
has been a little bit all over the place
the last two years have been better
last year was clearly his best year of
playing football
and i was wondering what they would do
there i look at the jets though and i
think logically they probably look like
we don't have one blue chipper in our
secondary so we can't let that guy go
he's the only like standout football
player they got plus
they got a boatload of money so you
don't let them out the door when you
just kind of
connect those dots and it makes sense
yeah and uh look it's a device
that is there to help the teams keep
guys off
the market and uh that's what the
cowboys did last year with dak
and that's one of the reasons why they
got backed into a corner this year
because over the years there have been
advances made
by the union to make it harder to do
multiple tags and for most players it's
virtually impossible to do a third tag
so for guys like justin
simmons and brandon scherff they're
going to have all the leverage going
forward because next year
highly unlikely that either of those
guys will be tagged
again and we could see another kirk
cousins trumaine johnson he gets
forgotten in all this he did two years
under the tag with the rams hit the open
market so it delays your entry to the
open market
it doesn't eliminate it entirely and for
a position like quarterback chris
that's the one where you're taking on
less physical risk the irony is dak
prescott broke his ankle this year
yeah but for some of these other
positions you don't want to carry the
injury risk
for two more years you want to get that
long-term deal back to what dan campbell
said last week franchise tag oh i'd like
to get the franchise tag that's a nice
chunk of money
yeah it's not nearly as nice as the
chunk of money you get when you hit the
open market yeah that that's right you
know you
and especially like you said it
non-quarterbacks i mean
if if justin simmons broke his ankle the
way
dak prescott did that would be a game
changer a team would be concerned what
do you mean his job is
back pedaling and jamming that foot into
the ground
and exploding and running four four in
one direction and
you know coming downhill and breaking
down and making tackles against running
backs on the open field
so that's where it's a lot riskier for
for the
every down you know football player
that's not a quarterback in the nfl
i'm going to be interested to see where
this franchise tag thing goes first off
i mean are you feel like we're it's
going to be the end of today i mean
what's your thought there i mean when is
the nfl going to let everybody know here
well
it's whatever the nfl and the nflpa
agree to it and the salary cap
every year is a negotiation people think
that the union and the league get
together once every 10 years or so
and they have one negotiation they do a
cba and then there's nothing else to
talk about
every year the salary cap is the product
of a detailed negotiation between the
league and the union
and the other they can they can
negotiate on anything they want anytime
they can change
any aspect of their broader deal anytime
they want and they can agree among
themselves
to bump back by a day a week whatever
it just needs to get done before that
two day window
opens next monday at noon i believe on
communicating with the agents of the
guys who are
to become free agents it needs to be it
needs to be applied by then so they
could push it all the way to sunday if
you wanted to right
and uh and maybe they will but they got
to they they have to at some point
figure out what the cap is going to be
i've heard 182 to 183 million and again
some teams want it to be lower some
teams want it to be higher for the union
it's always
make it as high as it can be although
you could have some younger players in
the union saying i don't care how low it
is this year my salary's locked in for
the next two or three seasons i'd rather
save some of that money into future
years when i become a free agent well
that's right
you're right there's two sides and
within the two sides
there's levels and layers of conflicting
interests on whether to have the cap low
or whether to have the cap well
the young players have not enough say i
mean that's what we've seen here i mean
that's an issue it's like what bruce
arians brought up a few weeks ago too
like oh yeah the vets don't want off
season workouts so so the young guys can
never develop or do anything
you know too many of the things right
now being decided by the nflpa are
favoring the veteran football players
and not keeping into
you know keeping in mind you know what's
best for young guys as they come up the
pipes and do those type of things so
uh it's a real aspect no doubt about it
i'm interested i really am because you
know yeah there's money problems this
year but gosh
there are some players like you
mentioned a few where i just go
they can't let this guy out of town that
will be a huge
loss for their football team even with
you know the reduced salary cap and
things like that and i'm
truly intrigued by gallaudet robinson
leonard williams of the new york giants
john johnson the safety for the los
angeles rams
and aaron jones you know we talked about
that too what is green bag gonna do with
aaron jones
they don't really have a home run hitter
on their offense devonte adams is not
that kind of guy
he's 10 yards 12 yards he's that kind of
guy he's not 70 yards aaron jones is the
only guy
that can do that type of stuff on their
offense for for me other than valdez
scantling going deep from time to time
so
uh i i would that's another one you're
in a super bowl window you're going to
really let aaron jones walk
away and take another weapon from rogers
and all that so there's a few i got my
eye on here
there was movement last year of the
franchise tag deadline for reasons
unrelated to determining the cap it was
more along the lines of what was going
to happen with the negotiation
as related to the cba that was being
discussed between the league and the
union last year so it just shows that
they can basically do whatever they want
to do they can bump this deadline around
there just is a point where it becomes
impractical and i'd say
anything beyond sunday at 4 pm eastern
it becomes unpractical because
as of monday at noon eastern that's when
as a practical matter the market opens
that's when teams and agents can start
talking officially
about contracts and they can fit not
officially reach deals but unofficially
reach deals
obviously you need to know which guys
are off limits or which guys would be
subject to
the potential compensation of two
first-round picks if you do work out a
deal can they push that date back though
that that's
that's a like well you can push that
back you can push the start of the
league year back you can do whatever you
want yeah you can you can
yeah i mean that that's that they can
push free agency back and i've
i've had some agents argue they should
push free agency back
for reasons more related to the pandemic
although
i it just seems like we're making
progress there and that's good i don't
want to jinx it by talking about it too
much but
they can make it whenever they want
right they had free agency after the
draft in 2011 because of the lockout
they can do free agency whenever they
want and they can work backward they can
say free agency starts this day
and we're gonna work backwards so uh i i
don't see any reason to delay
free agencies starting on march 17. look
at some point you've got to set
the salary cap at some point you've got
to reach the agreement
and uh you know that's got to happen
if and and so you need a hard deadline
you need a real deadline i think from
the union's perspective from the
player's perspective we want the market
to open let's go march 7
uh march 17 is when it opens so we got
we got to work backward and get all
these other deadlines in place what are
the rules right now for t
like players free agents college guys
like going
in and the the facilities like they're
not letting the college guys do that yet
right now team visits
right team visits with players that's
not happening it's all virtual
yeah players can go if they pass
an on-site pcr test like jj watt he went
to arizona last week right
and they can do a physical and they can
visit but they got to pass the pcr test
there's been no indication yet as to
whether or not that's going to change
for free agency remember last year
no visits no physicals it screwed some
guys up like cam newton
and it just made a weird kind of a thing
where you're doing all these deals sight
unseen
up this year the you can
for now they haven't changed it yet but
for now you can make the visit take the
physical
in the new city as long as you pass that
pcr test
on the way in the door chris yeah okay
all right so that's good i mean that is
an important piece of you know
piece of the process getting to know
guys a little getting to poke and prod
them as we've talked about
especially when there's so many of these
deals every year before they ever show
up like that
disaster yeah yeah i i know you're right
i i don't understand that at all
but uh man it makes it hard on these
football teams to not see some of these
college guys coming out in the draft in
person get around them the free agents
you want to know the guy
before you make a big investment and
teams are a little handicapped as far as
that's concerned right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports